Another question that comes to us is regarding the the CPC limits. Some people want to know
how do you know or what is too high for CPC. So when we go through our Google Keyword Planner
it gives us a range of the low page and the top of page bid. Sometimes those are within a few dollars
of each other. Sometimes there's wide variance. Sometimes you have a low page bid at like six
dollars and the top of page bid could be closer to thirty dollars. When you have those big ranges
it makes it a little more difficult to figure out. But what I typically see when I get that
question is that, and this is an example I have on the screen right now, is that you're choosing
a large city which you're not supposed to do and you're choosing a very competitive niche which
you're not supposed to do. So when we see a large city in a competitive niche you're going to see
that larger more expensive CPC. What is too much? You know according to the training we try to keep
it between like five like around the five dollar range on Simrush. As you go into the ad you'll
see sometimes it's a little bit more. But here I have something brought up. This is an ad that we
were running for Nick for a little while and it was for duck cleaning. I believe that the website
was starting to get some its own organic leads but we were having CPC of up to forty dollars per
click on some of these. And you can see here that we're able to be really good and we're able to
play and keep our average CPC in the ten dollar range and sometimes the fourteen dollar range.
But knowing that niche, and this is for the New Orleans area, so big city, expensive niche, knowing
that it is we know that we're going to spend more. We know it's going to cost a lot to get those leads
and so for us running that ad we weren't afraid of having those thirty dollar clicks because we
know what we were going to get on the other side. We know what niche we were playing in. So for you
guys if you're seeing something that seems way high up there I'd ask you to go back look at the
population of the city. Look at the population that you're running your ads over and think about
what niche you're running because that's typically where I see where that becomes an issue.